de quoi que c'est qu'on se parle
aujourd'hui ça est ce que ça vous parle
ça c'est nouveau petit buzz de google ce
sont les google pixels buzz pixels se
sont particulièrement ce que sont les
google les pixels bugs assez regardez
c'est écrit noir sur blanc
voilà ça et ça c'est pas mal enfin c'est
ce qu'on va regarder enfin c'est ce que
vous allez dire bas mais moi ça me tente
bien regarde là pour parler des pixels
buzz on a besoin et bien des pixels bugs
et d'un pixel
alors si je vous ai pris un pixel 3 mais
qui encore très actuel et qui fonctionne
bien donc ça c'est bien on va d'abord
regarder cette petite boîte alors la
boîte à lettres est simple un très
classique bon je pense à le tourner la
boîte pendant des heures on l'a fait ça
existe pratiques et regarder ça souffle
comme ça on retrouve à l'intérieur ces
petits pixels un petit pixel gésù devant
quelques instants j'ai déjà enlevé ya un
an vous allez petit emballage très
mignon c'est sympathique c'est très bien
et à l'intérieur on vient retrouver un
câble usb à usb c'est très sain pour
venir les recharges et là des petits en
bout qui situe bien la toile truc vous
avez des petits en bout pour la taille
oui parce qu'on n'a pas tous les mêmes
tailles d'oreilles ce qui fait que vous
avez trois tailles du tout petits aux
moyens ou très très grand donc ça c'est
cool vous avez une petite notice pour
venir lire des choses sympathiques que
vous avez crié google coucou comment ça
se passe tak tak on vous explique tout
bon ça je vais le faire dans la vidéo
donc c'est pas la peine de lire regarder
la vidéo jusqu'au bout comme ça vous
saurez tout et puis voilà quelques kills
info sur le garde donc ça c'est bien
maintenant ce qui nous intéresse c'est
ici donc moi pour l'instant je les ai
pas du tout altérée
alors ce qu'il faut faire normalement on
va voir si ça marche on les ouvre et ils
devraient être reconnues pour l'instant
pas oui ça y est je vais se connecter
configurez votre contenu multimédia
préfère unia ok ça roule j'accepte bien
sûr que j'accepte essayez vos écouteurs
alors premier écouteurs je positionne
l'autre en fait les ennemis je pivote ma
tête et j'ai déjà de la musique la hache
un petit tuto donc là une faille puis
étant déjà puis deux fois qui te suivent
en lien le titre précédent
trois fois pour relier en arrière voir
l'état de recharge pas si génial ça fait
la vidéo à ma place on peut balayer
l'écran olala c'est magnifique même pas
une vidéo tout est écrit ici regardez
c'est formidable ça vous explique tout
génial j'ai pouvoir poser mon truc
arrêter la vidéo ça sert fait
strictement rien il faut toi ma place
hop on active laxiste en google c'est
formidable autoriser l'assistant à lire
une notification au vote
oui au tac j'autorise je suis vraiment
pris par la main de a à z en ça c'est
génial active et l'assistant est prêt
alors les petits bugs en de même bon
c'est tout ce que le plus simple vous
avez cette petite elle est ici ici ça
être un détecteur de présence dans vos
oreilles pour savoir si vous avez mis
aussi vous les avez pas mis les petits
plats pour la recharge le micro à vous
avec 2 micros par écouteurs c'est peut
être en dessous ça doit être l'autre ici
hockey plutôt cool donc ça ça marche
là vous avez un petit voyant deux
batteries qui vous indiquent qu'il est
chargé lorsqu'il est blanc comme ça
c'est qu'il est bien vide à charger
petite boîte sympa et si vous avez un
petit bouton pour venir les intérêts la
question est qu'est ce que ça donne
quand google décide de lancer des petits
bugs à moins de 100 euros
et bah ça donne ça et ça c'est
franchement pas mal déjà parce que ces
petits parce que ça marche bien parce
que on est dans l'air du temps on est
franchement dans l'air du temps y'a rien
de bien surprenant rien de bien d'un
goal danse on les prend pas on l'aimé on
les tourne rond lévis comme si on
voulait s'est enfoncé le plus loin dans
les oreilles possible et une fois que
vous les avez ça marche d'hier alors ici
vous n'avez pas de réduction active des
bruits donc si c'est la réduction
passive la réduction passive pour ceux
qui ne savent pas en fait ça fait un
truc tout bête vous bouche à oreille ou
à la réduction passive de bruit voilà
avec vos doigts ça marche de la même
manière c'est à dire obstrué qu'avait
dit il et le truc qui est vraiment
intéressant ici c'est moins de 100 euros
moins 100 euros prendre des petits bugs
signé google vous pouvez les utiliser
comme je lisais sur radio c'est sur
android mais c'est sûr qu'ici le plus
important et le plus intéressant c'est
l'écosystème android c'est pour un
smartphone de google xl5 pixels 4 ou
tout autre produit qui va venir
supporter de l'android donc à vous de
choisir il ya plein de produits
différents différentes marques c'est à
dire maintenant tout ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de savoir est ce que ces
pixels bugs series à pizza on va les
appeler une bonne qualité sonore que ça
vaut pas le coup est ce que c'est
intéressant ce que ses patins mais
justement
et ça c'est super intéressant parce
qu'en fait ils ont bien bossé ils ont
fait un truc qui pourrait paraître un
peu basique en rien une application on
va se remettre derrière on va regarder
les quelques paramètres dans quelques
instants
il y en a pas des caisses mais ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est efficace ça marche bien
c'est ça qui réellement intéressant qui
apporte en termes d'usagé vous avez au
niveau équaliseur une case à actionner
une case à activer et si vous désactivez
pas c'est dommage parce que vous serez
vraiment en dessous il faut l'activer
c'est l'amplification dévasté une fois
de plus dans quelques instants en
semaine- ariary en garde ça ça vous
permet d'enrichir
le show significativement on va pas
aller aussi loin que ce qu'on pourra
retrouver avec d'autres écouteurs avec
deux bugs mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ici ils ont réussi le tour de force
vous avez des graves qui sont présents
quand vous exposer cette petite case
amplification des basques ça ronronne
vous avez du corps sans couvrir c'est un
petit peu les bas médium on va pas avoir
le son le plus brillant au niveau des
aigus mais vous avez un truc qui marche
ou bien qui marche vraiment bien qui est
extrêmement cohérent et que vous avez du
son de qualité pour 99 euros
donc plus vous assurez classe sur google
a vraiment bien réussi son pari a pris
en tout cas intéressant c'est que il
optimise l'expérience google c'est
google qui sont malins ils savent tout
faire fonctionner en forme peut être me
dit igoogle ou un petit ok google il
voulu poser des questions et google
monte le son parce que si vous n'avez
pas de possibilité de venir monter le
son non pas la possibilité vous demander
à google alors vous êtes dans un
transport en public c'est un peu la
limite vous êtes dans le métro et dans
le train ou sorcière vous voulez pas
trop vous faire repérer et google n'ont
que son c'est pas très très discret
après vous avez le bouton sur smartphone
vous pouvez le faire et puis vous peut
lui demander par exemple de vous aider
pour la traduction et google et deux
mois par les japonais deux mois par les
anglais deux mois par les coréens j'en
sais rien il vous aidera sur la
traduction instantanée donc c'est plein
de petites astuces qui sont fectivement
liés à l'écosystème google alors après
google instant vous retrouver avec des
écouteurs mais c'est vrai qu'ici c'est
la force de google c'est que google sait
faire du google c'est je marchais
parfaitement bien avec google et si vous
le mettez sur un pixel si vous le mettez
sur android bien évidemment sur allier
où elles sont peu mais vraiment faire
tous les sur un android c'est vraiment
ce qu'on fait ce qu'on veut et bien vous
avez une expérience qui complètement
maximiser qui elle revient avec du son
qui envoie saas et est accessible ici je
suis sur la version bêta de l'apli donc
vous l'aurez peut-être pas exactement de
la même manière dont sont peut-être les
choses différemment
en tout cas ce qu'on voit ici c'est
qu'on voit le niveau de charge on voit
le niveau de charge de l'étui ça marche
très très bien que tu très pratique
grand classique là dessus ce qui va
m'intéresser 6 et les commandes tactiles
on les voit ça vous indique ce que vous
avez à faire ça vous retrouver dans le
tutoriel vous pouvez l'activer le
désactiver vous appuyez une fois plein
une fois pause vous appuyé deux fois
titres suivants vous appuyez trois fois
morceaux précédents vous appuyer une
fois vous décrochez vous appuyé deux
fois vous raccrochez où vous dégagez
l'appel lorsque vous voulez pas répondre
à ça vole mais ici donc les commandes
sont très simples n'y a pas de commande
de volume comme je vous le disais mais
on y arrive avec son smartphone où on
arrive en appelant google est là ici une
case à cocher qui est hyper importante
est celle là amplification des basses
saiful cochet si ça vous le cocher pas
vous n'allez pas profiter de la
meilleure expérience c'est ça qu'il faut
faire c'est ça qu'il faut utiliser et là
tout de suite ça passe vraiment dans
tout à l'heure après il ya une autre
option celle de son actif alors ça va
permettre de venir réguler
votre niveau sonore en fonction du bruit
environnant par défaut et décoché ce qui
veut donc dire que lorsque vous êtes
dans une pièce et qui a beaucoup de
bruit et bien ça va monter le son et dès
qu'un peu moins de bruit ça va le bcsa
c'est pas mal parce que ça va venir
quelque part protéger un petit peu vos
oreilles lorsqu'il a pas beaucoup de
volume le son est beaucoup plus bas
alors qu'avant on était plus forts et
bien sadia bcb ces décès parce que
naturellement on n'a pas tendance à le
faire c'est vrai que je sais pas vous
mais voir ce que j'écoute de la musique
j'ai monté le son c'est très rare que je
viens de baisser le volume ici et
pourtant il faudra le faire mise en
pause automatique lorsque vous retirez
vos écouteurs bon voilà sélectionné mais
bon à vous de voir on n'est pas bien
obligée là dessus mise à jour on peut
faire ici au keynote l'assistant google
a créé notification et les préférences
que vous venez retrouver ici
actionner le riz google ça ça me paraît
quand même plutôt pas mal et c'est ça
qui vous permettra d'en tirer le
meilleur parti on est sur un produit
google il faut en profiter
donc voyez il n'y a pas grand grand
chose c'est pas une usine à gaz mais ce
qui est présent ici ça marche bien c'est
simple c'est efficace souvent ce que je
fait reprocher à des marques ce qui met
pas des coalisés réveil si vous avez pas
d'écho eliza mais par contre vous et ses
petites options là qui marche bien et
puis franchement le son est très
équilibré à l'intérieur ça des petits
haut parleurs de 12 mm ils sont
certifiés ipx4 alors qu'est ce que c'est
que ipx4 hélas si vous les prenez pour
aller courir aller faire un peu de sport
elle et j'en sais rien moi vous balader
qui fait très chaud et que vous
dégouliner de partout et vous ne pouvez
plus et bien fait ils sont résistants à
l'eau et à la sueur pour autant on va
pas aller nager dans une piscine avec
clairement mais si par contre vous êtes
dehors il pleut si vous transpirez
énormément si vous faites du sport vous
faites du vélo ce que vous voulez pas de
souci là dessus vous avez la
certification donc ils sont étanches
niveau autonomie
google nous donne 5 heures d'écouté de
musique avec votre petit buzz et 2h30 en
appel et et c'est là où ça devient
intéressant c'est que vous prenez votre
petite boîte voit la petite boîte qui
est là vous pouvez le recharger
plusieurs fois grâce à son petit boîtier
volonté jusqu'à 24 heures de musique qui
va écouter vingt quatre heures de
musique non-stop bas personne pourquoi
parce qu'au bout de cinq heures vous
devez les enlever les mets dedans ça les
recharges tous mis bout-à-bout ça vous
fait 24 heures musique et jusqu'à 12
heures d'appels bluetooth 5.0 est dispo
en deux couleurs ici c'est le naturel
mont blanc c'est ça la couleur ils ont
marqué résolument blanc et vous avez une
couleur plus foncée c'est la couleur
rouille alors moi j'aime bien comme ça
on est dans l'esprit google
le design est sympa c'est pas mal on
n'est pas sur les écouteurs les plus
performants on n'est pas sur les buzz de
dingo du marché mais a un petit peu
moins de 100 euros à 99 euros sont super
bien positionné la qualité est là
l'audio marche bien l'expérience et la
cdu google google ses phares de google
il fait du google ait fait du google
sont des petits bugs à moins de 100
euros
ça marche bien venez vraiment actionner
cette petite case amplification des
basses encore vous ne profiterez pas
d'une bonne expérience et là ça vient
vraiment tout changé lorsque vous la
d'actionner personnellement j'aime bien
la qualité il a vraiment une fois plus
je le dis à qualité qualité qualité
c'est vraiment des super petit buzz à
peine un petit peu moins de 100 euros
moi j'aime bien je trouve qu'ils ont
vraiment bien bossé et une fois de plus
google va-t-il vraiment cette cette
notion de vire agrandir leur écosystème
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous avez vu
google lance on ouvre enfin on va ouvrir
à new york alors on est passé au niveau
de chelsea au niveau de leur bureau en
face de chelsea market à manhattan et
bien ils ont ouvert un magasin google
physique c'est le premier magasin google
physique au monde vous allez pouvoir me
racheter votre ardeur google et
notamment ceux là alors soyez
tranquilles et soyez rassurés on peut
venir les acheter ailleurs que vous
publiez la new york pour une réalité
qu'on va les acheter par exemple sur
internet vous pouvez venir valais
commandé via le lien en bas dans la
description l'heure pas tout de suite
tout de suite parce que quand je sors eh
bien je vais à peine d'être annoncées
dont cas pas tout de suite tout de suite
le lien mais je veux rajouter si vous
avez des petits écouteurs un un petit
peu moins de 100 euros et que vous êtes
vraiment foule android que vous adorez
l'expérience google et vous êtes 100%
google ça c'est bien ça ça marche bien
il n'y a pas d'autres solutions il n'y a
pas d'autres écouteurs qui marche bien
mais c'est vrai que toi reconnaître que
là dessus ils ont vraiment bien réussi
leur copie et une fois de plus moins de
100 euros
malin google à vous dire vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas là juste en bas
dans les commentaires est ce que vous
êtes un google addict est ce que vous
aimez l'expérience google est ce que
vous aimez les produits google est ce
que ça vous botte
et surtout qu'est ce que vous pensez de
salars ce tout petit projet type pixels
bud a series il pas ce que vous en
pensez en dans commentaires des silences
et des gros bisous
l'amour est de 15